more now on how the administration's
actions could have a negative impact on
journalists and their sources
here's fox news media analyst and host
of fox's media buzz howard kurtz the
disclosure about New York Times reporter
Ali Watkins set off alarm bells in the
news business as journalists realized
that president Trump's Justice
Department is willing to secretly obtain
a journalist phone and email records in
pursuit of leaks Free Press advocates
are backing the paper stating that the
move will endanger reporters ability to
promise confidentiality to their sources
and make it harder to shine a much
needed light on government actions but
the case is complicated by Watkins
three-year romantic relationship with
former Senate Intel official James Wolfe
who was arrested yesterday she was a
reporter for BuzzFeed when she broke
this story last year on Carter Paige a
former Trump advisor met with a Russian
spy Watkins and Wolff exchanged 124
electronic messages that day the
indictment says spoke for seven minutes
after the story was posted and another
15 minutes after she appeared on MSNBC
why did Carter page confirm this to you
and what was his ass what was his
effects toward the toward this
information and it becoming public he
was very forthcoming with it I mean I've
been doing a lot of reporting on it so
knew that it was him in the document
Wolfe texted her months later that I
always tried to give you as much
information that I could so you could
get that scoop before anyone else I felt
like I was part of your excitement
Watkins once tweeted the view of the
committee where wolf worked that
Trumpster lawyers will leak info and
blame the committee she has denied
receiving leaks from Wolfe Eric Holder
secretly obtained records from AP
staffers and from former fox
correspondent james rosen in the obama
administration
attorney general jeff sessions says he's
conducting three times as many
investigations i have this warning for
would-be leakers don't do it for the
past several months we've already made
changes and are seriously ramping up our
efforts beyond the personal details
involving Ally Watkins for prosecutors
to go after reporters records and in
this case encrypted apps strikes at the
heart of journalism the ability to
promise sensitive sources
their identities will be protected Brett
how are thanks